aussi le travail sur la ferme c'est à
tous les jours c'est très tôt c'est
physique parfois nous agriculteurs
connaissent des difficultés
il ya des gens pour les aider on va
d'ailleurs en parle avec ellen bourgoin
travailleurs de rang l'association au
coeur des familles agricoles non merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous expliquez nous
tout d'abord si vous faites je crois que
c'est la première fois que j'entends ce
titre travailleurs de rang et vous êtes
seulement 7 de ce que j'ai compris le au
québec pour l'organiser au coeur des
familles agricoles avec cet organe est
ce là on est 6 3
il y en a d'autres qui sont en plus de
100 partenariaux puis un autre air de
rang qui est indépendante mais bref
c'est tout le temps le même travail
mon travail c'est d'accompagner soutenir
l'agriculteur l'agricultrice qu'il ya
des moments plus difficiles
nous on est vraiment on va dire la
première ligne pour offrir des services
de psycho sociaux avec eux puis à aux
organismes et on le redit est
agriculteur c'est à tous les jours
parfois n'a pas de vacances ça commence
très très tôt c'est difficile convient
dans à peu près à chaque semaine est
agriculteur au québec provient de la
période de l'année puis du type de
production
maintenant je donne un examen c'est sûr
que le maraîcher du barça peut être 10
15 ans 50 jours à l'été ça peut monter à
85 à 3 semaines - sont bons avec
production laitière et l'hiver juste par
les trains et sans un bon 35-40 en plus
la 4s on rajoute un seul était dans les
chais les travaux on peut monter à 100
facilement en ce moment c'est ce qui se
passe le sont en train de faire les
coupes donc ils sont et dans l'étape et
lance ses demandes
absolument et lorsque ça va pas la ferme
ça va pas la maison qu'elles sont
souvent les difficultés dont on vous
parle très souvent votre avec la famille
puis quand des conflits familiaux mais à
terme dans l'entreprise les avoir aussi
à la maison chaque saison que ce ça
vient jouer beaucoup surcharge de
travail n 2 je pense que c'est du son
dans plusieurs secteurs sont le plus
accrues de pénurie y en a dans le
secteur agricole
mais oui en europe cette semaine un
garde donc ça devient des horaires
atypiques
donc c'est pour tout le monde qui va
indisponible puis pouvoir que c'est
physique aussi fait que ce congrès
ajoutant moi d'aller dans ce que je vois
dans les producteurs qui viennent à me
rencontrer
beaucoup des problèmes de transfert de
ferme c'est pas nécessairement le désir
de la ferme exactement mon aussi bon
accueil à des divorces de séparation
mais nous ça vient jouer parce qu'au
travers de tous au bate d'avoir ingéré
une garde partagée au travers des vaches
au travers des deux voies au travail
donc on va jouer puis même si on regarde
la météo aussi et on ait eu l'année de
l'été dernier il des sécheresses mais ce
souhait que là ça vient affecter les
chasser ça vient tout à fait de
présenter celle encore cette année est
ce que vous sentez vous a plu est ce que
vous sentez de plus en plus de détresse
la porte de nos fermiers est ce que ça
va en augmentant
mais je sais pas si ça va mais moi je
pense que on n'en parle plus qu'avant je
pense qu'il ya plus de des tristes mais
je pense qu'on n'en parle plus puisque
de moins en moins tabou on en est plus
conscient je pense que les producteurs
en parler en parler peut simplement au
garde des sceaux à la maison que l'eau
on est en plus axée peut-être aux
réseaux sociaux des organismes comme le
mien au coeur des familles agricoles lui
ils viennent pas en parler un peu plus
mais
c'est ce que je sais et vous tous
difficiles mais on en a plus avec ce
qu'il faut faire attention aussi au
niveau du bien-être du maquereau sauce
questionner un prix et ça fait rebondir
sur ma prochaine question vous ai parlé
aussi du taux de suicide j'ai
l'impression que ce double défi parce
que on a l'impression que les
agriculteurs ce ne sont pas les plus
loquaces
certains souffrent en silence ont de la
misère à parler à s'exprimer mais des
hommes puis aussi beau et aussi des
agricultrices pour faut pas l'oublier
effectivement vous ne parliez d'un
double défi le défi c'est vraiment de
les mobiliser pour qu'ils viennent dans
nos services une fois par exemple qui
sont volontaires qui acceptent de
consulter une fois que la demande des
faits nous ils vont parler d'eux des
fruits peuvent être trois heures dans
mon bureau le s'assemblent iodé l'armée
d'accord on est capable de travailler
avec un plan d'action jeunesse à venir
aussi de la tourache et l'entourage qui
va nous appliquons nous référer le faire
le conjoint
l'inculte à l'agricultrice qui vont
moins bien sûr un déclic en quelque
sorte au cours de ce bruit parler oui
même souvent ça va être un déclic
physique la personne a mal au dos s'est
blessé on va passer par le pur très
consulté le travailleur de rue
merci beaucoup madame bourgoin de votre
travail et on rend hommage aussi à ceux
qui me nourrissent à chaque jour donc à
ses agriculteurs agricultrices merci
d'abord est avec nous merci je sentais
une visite le numéro de téléphone les
gens connaissent de d'agriculteurs venin
le même temps donc c'est dans la 4 5 0
ce suisse 6 9 9,5 à flot
pour éviter le plancher absolu merci
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup à vous
mairie